I think the media, the media is the ones who've
done the worst job so far with the 2020 election,
and when I say that, here's what I mean, seven,
eight weeks ago, who was the darling of the
media?
That would be Beto O'Rourke.
Do you remember him?
I know a lot of people have already said,
oh my God, I thought he had dropped out.
We better work is still running for president.
It's just he's not getting that.
The glorious media coverage that he was getting
in the early days.
He was going to be the savior of the Democratic
Party right now I guess who may, or Pete,
maybe he's the one who was getting a lot of
attention.
Everybody's focused on him and namerd with
him.
He speaks a lot of languages.
He plays instruments.
He's a nice sweet guy.
Week on policy, very weak on policy.
Probably doesn't have a big chance of beating
Donald Trump in 2020, but he is, the media
is flavor of the month and next month they'll
probably be a new one and so on and so forth
and so on and so forth because the media coverage
of 2020 is already complete garbage.
It's absolutely infuriating, but it's not
just their coverage of picking and choosing
which candidate they want to lift up.
And uh, you know, they also Biden who's gotten
more coverage than all of the other people
running combined.
It's the fact that they're burying certain
people.
Elizabeth Warren, only in the last, you know,
10 days finally started getting the media
coverage that she deserves.
I mean, this woman has more plans than all
of the other candidates combined, basically.
And they always treated her like an afterthought.
Camilla Harris, whether you love her or whether
you hate or you got to agree that the media
is doing a really bad job with her.
In fact, all of the women running for president
seemed to get buried by the media.
So here's my quick advice.
Don't pay attention to the horse race.
Find a candidate whose values and ideals and
plans fit within your values and ideals and
plans and the things you want to see happen
to this country.
Port them.
Ignore the media, enjoyed of course, of course.
Race.
Educate yourself on getting cousins.